now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
yeah this was a special night for pete
davidson and kim kardashian and it's
looking like he's paying tribute to the
romantic moment
yep let us explain
on monday kim shared these intimate pics
of her and pete to instagram
hanging by the pool and hanging on each
other now some eagle-eyed fans are
taking a closer look at this snap in
particular if you zoom in pete appears
to have some new ink and well the tattoo
seemingly reads quote jasmine and
aladdin
if we go all the way
you might like break me
yeah we know what this refers to i'm
just a little concerned that
physically uh
i can't handle you
kim and pete famously locked lips when
she hosted saturday night live i like
you just the way you are
now are you gonna kiss me or not
i sure am jasmine
as reality star explains to jimmy kimmel
pete later called in some favors at snl
kim is this the first time you kiss pete
yes that is
what became of this rug do you have this
now seems like you should
actually for valentine's day he got me
the rug in the whole outfits he did and
the little genie oh wow of course pete
not only has several tattoos dedicated
to his girlfriend he also has kim's name
branded on his chest yeah he has a few
tattoos a few cute ones you know that he
got um but this one is a it's not that
one the kim one isn't a tattoo it's
actually a branding so he's like i don't
want to be able to get rid of it or to
cover it up the other ones are like
cutesy things i think my favorite one
it says here it says my girl is a lawyer
and that one's really cute pete's sweet
tribute coincides with another big debut
life is good i have a new boyfriend i'm
just having a really good time he
appears alongside kim in this steamy
sneak peek for the kardashians hinting
we'll be seeing more of that romance in
season two
yeah do you want to shower with me
really quick
and when izzy sat down with kim and her
famous family to chat about their hulu
series she couldn't help but gush about
her man
what do you love about him what's your
favorite thing about him
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
that's my favorite thing that's the goal
is finding someone to do nothing with
it's the best because you can do
everything with totally but it's easy to
be distracted with people you can be
with anyone
distracted but you can't be with anyone
and do nothing
[Music]
you